vamos a tomarnos un triángulo a bs
arbitrario con la única condición de que
no sea un triángulo equilátero va y
vamos a dibujar algunas rectas notables
en este triángulo para ver si
encontramos algo padre bueno déjame
empezar dibujando las media tristes para
construir la media triz de ave tenemos
que considerar su punto medio y trazar
una perpendicular a ave entonces déjame
tomar ahí el punto medio y trazar una
perpendicular más o menos algo como de
este estilo vale entonces tenemos que
este segmento es igual a este segmento
de acá y que este ángulo de aquí es
recto bueno de manera similar para
trazar la perpendicular abc
tenemos que considerar el punto medio
más o menos como por aquí este segmento
es igual estoy acá y tenemos que trazar
la perpendicular algo digamos de este
estilo
y finalmente déjame trazar la
perpendicular acá creo que ya sabes qué
voy a hacer voy a voy a poner aquí el
punto medio y voy a trazar una recta
perpendicular y ya mostramos que estas
tres media tristes pasan por un mismo
punto entonces déjame pintarlas así de
tal forma que concurran aquí en este
punto de acá esto de aquí es
perpendicular hasta que es perpendicular
y este punto donde concurren las tres
media tristes le llamamos el círculo
centro del triángulo déjame indicarlo
estoy aquí es decir con un centro
y se llama el circo un centro porque es
el centro de una circunferencia
circunscrita a abc osea que pasa por los
vértices ave y ser bueno ahora déjame
dibujar las medianas del triángulo las
medianas las voy a pintar con este color
azul y simplemente consisten en unir un
vértice con el punto medio opuesto
entonces tendría que tratar esta recta
de aquí
y esta recta de acá
y finalmente esta recta de acá entonces
esas tres medianas también ya vimos que
pasan por un mismo punto este punto de
acá y a ese punto le llamábamos que
llamábamos el centro hoy desde el
triángulo el centro también garabí
centro o centro de masa del triángulo
vale bueno entonces ya tenemos el
círculo centro y el centro y de déjame
dibujar ahora las alturas para encontrar
el otro centro para dibujar las alturas
simplemente tenemos que dibujar
perpendiculares desde cada uno de los
vértices al lado opuesto entonces
quedaría algo más o menos así entonces
dc vamos a trazar una perpendicular como
por ahí ahí está ahora debe también una
perpendicular va a quedar más o menos
por ahí y finalmente desde a también
vamos a trazar la altura que también
tiene que pasar por este punto entonces
quedaría más o menos algo así entonces
estas tres rectas son perpendiculares a
los lados
perpendiculares a los lados y además
pasan por un mismo punto vale a ese
punto por donde pasan las tres alturas
le llamamos el [ __ ] centro del triángulo
por todo el centro
del triángulo bueno nuestro centro nada
más le voy a poner así sale a otro
centro bueno entonces ya tenemos estas
cosas bien especiales y bien padres que
están sucediendo verdad tenemos que
estas tres rectas pasan por este punto
estas tres rectas pasan por este punto y
estas tres pasan por este punto s están
suficientemente especial porque
usualmente tres rectas pues no tendrían
por qué pasar por un punto pero aquí
tenemos tres ternas de rectas que pasan
por mismos puntos entonces eso está muy
bonito está muy padre pero resulta que
hay algo mucho más interesante
sucediendo aquí resulta que estos tres
puntos del [ __ ] centro el centro de y el
circo un centro los tres están alineados
es decir existe una recta que pasa por
los tres eso esta súper padre bueno si
tuviéramos un triángulo equilátero esos
tres serían iguales entonces en este
caso no habría una recta pero en otro
caso esos tres puntos son distintos y
resulta que siempre están en una misma
recta déjame dibujar la recta
quedaría más o menos algo como como así
vale
qué bonito quedó el dibujo ay se ven los
tres alineados en esta misma recta y
esta recta tiene un nombre especial
claro que debe tenerlo verdad porque es
algo padrísimo y es el nombre especial
pues como esta recta es mágica y así
súper especial entonces tiene el nombre
de un matemático que casi siempre se le
atribuyen cosas mágicas y súper
especiales a esta recta a esta recta de
aquí se le conoce como la recta de hoy
leer la recta recta de hoy leer y leer
se escribe y se lee oyler bueno y bueno
digo esto de que hoy leer siempre tiene
cosas mágicas y especiales que descubre
porque hay otras cosas que también se le
atribuyen a él y que están súper padres
por ejemplo esta identidad se conoce
como la identidad de oilers y ala y x pi
es igual a menos uno menos uno
y esto de aquí está súper padre y está
bien especial porque hay cuatro números
cuatro números relacionados entre sí que
vienen de interpretaciones muy distintas
del mundo
pero no entiendas que estoy diciendo
aquí pero cuando veas los vídeos de
cálculo vas a entender un poco mejor
pero básicamente la idea es que está
relacionado con crecimiento exponencial
esté con crecimiento de poblaciones
cosas de este estilo y es un número tal
que al elevarlo al cuadrado nos da menos
1 entonces es un número medio raro se
llama un número complejo y es la razón
del del perímetro de una circunferencia
a su diámetro y -1 es el inverso aditivo
de la identidad multiplica tiba que es
el 1 entonces aquí hay 4 números bien
especiales que están relacionados por
esta igualdad que se conoce como la
fórmula de hoy leer y de este lado
tenemos estos tres puntos que vienen de
cosas especiales de intersección de
rectas notables del triángulo y que
también están relacionados entre sí a
través de la recta en la recta de hoy
leer y bueno esto está súper padre hay
tres puntos aquí y si eso no se te hace
así
suficientemente padre de hecho hay más
puntos especiales sobre esta recta 1 que
es interesante es su punto medio bueno
claro que su punto medio su punto medio
pues debe de estar verdad pero lo que
está bien padre de ese punto medio
es que es el centro de una
circunferencia especial a ese punto
medio de ahí se le conoce como el centro
de la circunferencia de los nueve puntos
centro de la circunferencia sí
esencia de los nueve puntos de los nueve
puntos
juntos y esta es una circunferencia bien
especial porque pasa por nueve puntos
especiales del triángulo más o menos
déjame hacer el dibujo para que veas
cómo queda más o menos sería algo como
de este estilo como algo como de este
estilo y los nueve puntos especiales por
los que pasa son los puntos medios de
los lados los pies de las alturas del
triángulo y los puntos medios que van de
los vértices al [ __ ] centro este de acá
esté acá este de acá y este de acá pero
bueno aquí ya platicamos de muchas cosas
bien mágicas mejor vamos a dejarle hasta
aquí y en siguientes vídeos a lo mejor
platicamos un poco acerca de esta
circunferencia y veamos algunas de las
demostraciones de estas cosas
maravillosas